Speaker 1: . Listen, they simply will not
stop.
Another ballot audit is set to go forward
in Fulton County, Georgia.
And yes, this is for the twenty twenty presidential
election.
Now, let's sit back for a second and review.
Yes, obviously, Joe Biden won Georgia.
Yes.
Obviously, even if Biden lost Georgia, he
would still have the necessary 270 electoral
votes to be president of the United States.
Yes, obviously, the Georgia results have been
certified and confirmed and recounted and
audited for Joe Biden multiple times.
And nothing can change now.
And yes, obviously, Joe Biden has been president
for months.
And this isn't an absurd and humiliating fiasco
for Republicans, but they will not stop.
CNN reports that another ballot audit or audit,
as some say, is set to move ahead in Georgia's
most populous county after a judge ruled Friday
that absentee ballots could be unsealed for
parties looking to examine them for evidence
of fraud.
Georgia Republicans plan to bring in six so-called
experts.
By the way, sometimes you see these experts
and you say, dear God, they're going to bring
in six experts to look at the ballots and
see if they can determine whether there are
characteristics pointing to counterfeit ballots.
Now, remember, Georgia counties already did
the initial count, a hand audit, a rescan
of each ballot.
And every single one of those actions confirmed
that Joe Biden won Georgia.
You know who loves this decision, though,
about doing another audit?
Former Republican Senator Kelly Lefler from
Georgia, who was handily defeated by now Democratic
Senator Raphael Warnock.
She refers to him as radical liberal Raphael
Warnock.
She applauded this new audit, saying, quote,
Voter confidence in our election system is
the bedrock of our republic.
Unfortunately, inconsistencies in Fulton County's
November 20, 20 absentee ballots cast serious
doubt on voter's faith in our elections.
Now, one upside here just for hilarity is
that they won't even be given the real ballots
to review.
I love this.
They will be given scanned images of the ballots.
I don't know why I love that, but they're
not even going to let them put their hands
on the actual ballots.
Now, this wouldn't be so much an audit, but
an attempt to tamper, really.
So it's probably smart not to give them actual
ballots, but just the signed images.
And I read one commentary about this that
says, you know, allowing this to go forward
is a mistake because it's yet another seed
of doubt that gets planted in the minds of
those who want to believe this was stolen,
something that might convince someone that
there was fraud.
I think that that ship has long sailed.
If you think there was fraud, you think there
was fraud.
And none of this stuff matters.
You just think there was fraud.
Most people have moved on.
And another pseudo audit or forensic examination
of remember when they wanted to look at Bambu
fibers in Arizona or whatever?
I don't think it'll really make a difference
at this point in public opinion.
Now, what is the latest that a judge could
even allow them to do something like could
you continue auditing and reviewing ballots
from 20, 20 beyond the 20, 20 to mid midterm's?
I have no idea.
I don't know how long it's possible for this
to go on.
And of course, the troubling part of all of
this is you really can't prove a negative.
And this is we've done a lot of stories about
how conspiracy theories work and conspiracies
and conspiratorial thinking when they find
nothing for the second time and the third
time and the fourth time and the fifth time
they instead of saying there's probably nothing
to find, they say, you know, they've done
a really good job of hiding it.
If we did a sixth audit, we would then find
the smoking gun that we're waiting for.
The fact that we've not found anything in
four reviews is only evidence that they've
hidden the fraud really, really well.
And as I've said before, healthy skepticism
is good and thinking for ourselves is good
and understanding what is the foundation of
a belief.
How did I come to believe a certain thing?
That's all good.
Never ending skepticism.
If you never want to be satisfied, you can
find a way to never be satisfied.
And that's exactly what they are doing here.
And a real hallmark of conspiracy theorists
is that evidence for something counts as evidence
and lack of evidence for that.
Boeing also counts as evidence because hiding
the evidence is part of the plan, and when
you if you don't reason your way into a belief,
you're not going to get reasoned out of it.
And I've said that many times before, and
that's clearly a case of what's going on here.
But they're continuing to keep going.
That's in Georgia.
And we also have some more interesting news
now out
of Arizona.